good evening welcome to stratford-onaven
District Council planning committee my
name is councilor Lewis Adam I'm your
chairman for this evening I'll go
through some housekeeping to begin with
um there's no fire alarm that is planned
for this evening so it does go off
please make an orderly exit and there
must points across the road in the car
park by the pub
um please make sure your phones are on
silent and do not disturb the flow of
the meeting it is a meeting in public
not a public meeting so only those who
are registered to speak are permitted to
do so I'll call your name at the
appropriate time and give you further
instructions from that point on
the meeting is being recorded and
broadcast on our website
and I'll now introduce the top table
Democratic Services we have and Banks
our solicitor this evening is Amy
Shipley our planning manager is Richard
Gardner and our planning officers are
Charlotte Dix Victoria Kempton and Paul
Thompson Richard I believe you have a
statement you've prepared
come to assist members in their decision
taking thank you
thank you very much we can now move on
to the agenda then item one apologies
for absence
too many buttons apologies from
councilor Curtis
thank you very much item number two
disclosures of Interest
uh councilor
good evening chair
um I shall be standing down from the
committee for application 23 forward
slash zero one five two nine forward
slash o u t the application for more
moral and we'll be speaking on behalf of
both Parish Council and as the ward
member
thank you very much Council Keithley
yeah yes thanks chair
um I've got a declaration of interest
um I did send it to um Amy Shipley and I
I wrote a short email I'll just read you
what I said
I'd like to make a disclosure of
Interest relating to the application
2300518 which is um hogwood Farm in late
2019 I wrote Tesco's in response to a
challenge from farms not factories about
welfare standards of pork that Tesco was
selling and the essence of the issue was
that the um the Red Tractor scheme
whilst outwardly appearing to support
higher welfare standards didn't ensure
freedom to roam and I wanted Tesco's as
a retailer to to come into line with
some of the other retailers in in the
area as particularly in respect to the
rspca short scheme and I sent Amy um the
correspondence that I had with the
retailer but this was a matter with the
retailer it's some time ago
making that disclosure I'm willing to
confirm I've got no predetermination in
respect of this application and I got an
open mind to the merits or otherwise of
the application on policy grounds I also
visited the site but only on the um the
main road and the side road just to get
a visual
um impression of it for myself
thank you very much
any other disclosures of Interest
no in which case we move on to item
number three minutes
um so we've got three sets this evening
we've got the 2nd of August 2023 uh
everyone happy there's an accurate
record of the meeting agreed the 16th of
August 2023 green
Castle Harvey thank you uh can I take
you to page 10 and the reasons for
refusal
I don't doubt that the accuracy of the
reasons for refusals but I think they've
been conflated
there are two reasons set out there not
one and I would prefer if the record
could be amended so that they were
identified as two separate reasons
please
okay thank you councilor Harvey I'm
happy to
um take that to the planning manager and
we'll we'll address that within minutes
going forwards okay uh no further
comments
okay jolly good and then the last ones
were the 30th of August 2023
greed okay jolly good
okay in which case we can move on to our
first application item number four which
is application
2300518 ful hogwood Farms pillorton
Hersey Road oxhill
uh presenting officer is Charlotte Dix
and I believe you're ready so take it
away
thank you chair
the site is indicated on the map by the
black circle the application site is
located to the north of the a422 and
access from the Kyneton road to the east
of the site
the sites in the open Countryside
this slide shows the application site
edged in red it forms parts of a pig
rearing Enterprise which is part of a
wider 216 acre agricultural unit
the buildings you can see within the
site are agricultural and nature
so this slide shows the Redevelopment of
the pig sheds an erection of 10 knee
four bed dwellings this is a full
planning application for the works the
plan on the left hand side of the screen
shows the existing site plan with the
pig farm sheds grouped on the southern
part of the site
the plan on the right hand side shows
the proposed 10 dwellings with
Associated Garden space outbuildings and
residential paraphernalia with bunding
to the north of the site
wind turbines are also proposed
vehicular access would continue to be
provided from the Kyneton road to the
east by way of enlargement of the
existing two accesses
as shown on the map in the corner of the
slide with the arrow this shows that the
photo is taken from the crossroads to
the south of the site the a422 is
visible in the foreground with Kyneton
Road leading away from us
the first access into the site is
approximately where the tree can be seen
on this part of the the site
this photo is taken from further up
kindton Road indicated Again by the map
and the arrow
the tree is now visible centrally so the
first access into the site is visible
just beyond the trees and you can see
some of the Agricultural buildings on
the left hand side of the photo
this photo has taken moving further up
Kyneton road with a site on the left
hand side showing the established hedge
and showing the ground level rising
towards the North
this photo is of a longer distance view
taken as you travel along the a422
traveling towards the east you can see
the farm buildings fairly centrally
within the photo
so this photo is taken from a bridal way
to the northwest of the site known as
Marston Hill the bride away is at an
elevated position the farm is visible on
the second Ridge line
at this point here
so this photo is taken from within the
site Show an example of the range of
buildings within the site
and again this is another example of
some of the pig sheds within the site
so to give you an idea of the variety of
the design proposed some of the
elevation plans have been included in
the presentation so this plan shows the
proposed Northern elevation of plots two
and three with plot two being on the
left hand side
and then you can see three of the
proposed wind turbines
this plan shows the Western elevation of
plot 4.
with this one showing the southern
elevation of plot six
and lastly this shows the proposed
Northern elevation of plot 10.
so just to clarify there are updates
within the update sheet including
console T responses from the landscape
officer and agricultural consultant and
officer recommendation is to refuse the
application for redevelopment of the pig
farm to create 10 new dwellings in line
with the reasons and note on pages 42
and 43 of the agenda thank you chair
thanks very much Alice okay we now move
on to our first Speaker who's councilor
Catherine hewson
from piloton Hersey Parish Council good
evening uh yeah if you just take a seat
the button on the right turns the
microphone on
sorry could I just clarify who the other
speaker is
and your Parish counselor as well
okay give me two seconds it's going to
touch me um did you notify committee
services that you would be speaking
okay bear with me two seconds
uh I'm afraid we've not got a record
that you were registered to speak
um and for the purposes of openness with
and the dedication of time to certain
um speakers we we ask that everyone is
registered
um and we do have a registered speaker
from the parish council so I'd ask that
they're the only individual who actually
speaks on this item
okay thank you sorry about that
okay so sorry uh Casa Houston
um yes so it's the button on the right
hand side which makes a microphone go
live you've got three minutes I'll give
you a 30 second warning
um and let you know when when the time
is up uh otherwise it's uh up to you
take away
good evening representatives from both
Ox Hill and pilot and Hersey Parish
Council are in attendance this evening
as this application impacts both our
communities
we have seen unprecedented support for
the proposed development with over 30
letters of support for this application
and over 50 for the last refused
application
the Parish councils of both oxil and
pilot and Hersey support this
application for the following reasons
we believe the revised scheme addresses
the issues raised by the committee at
the last application with a detailed
flooding alleviation plan and increased
accessibility for Waste Management
as you are aware the site is currently
used for intensive Pig farming there are
numerous days of the year when this
results in a very unpleasant smell that
impacts our air quality in the
surrounding area
the farm has been subject to a number of
protests in recent years which has
reduced the viability of the current
business
these protests cause local residents
significant distress
locals trying to go about their normal
lives have felt intimidated by these
demonstrations and the presence of
anti-terrorist police trying to control
protesters
managing the demonstrations has a
knock-on effect to local policing whose
resources are already spread thin across
our rural area
the proposed scheme is of high quality
and delivers Sustainable Building using
a variety of materials and styles giving
the appearance of a traditional farmyard
which will enhance the site and fit well
into the landscape
as has been mentioned the scheme
proposes 10 large houses with a section
106 contribution to affordable homes
elsewhere in the area
we believe there would be a significant
reduction in both volume and weight of
traffic when compared with this current
business operation currently the site
receives HGB deliveries by Road and
large agricultural Machinery is used to
regularly move slurry off the farm via
the narrow rural roads
the design incorporates a generation of
sustainable energy by installing ground
Source heat pumps and solar panels
the scheme will improve the biodiversity
of this site with a variety of new
environments including hedgerows trees
Wildlife ponds bird and bat boxes while
retaining the existing Hedges to the
boundaries of the site
it is our opinion that this proposal
supports core strategy Countryside and
Villages policy as10 section residential
item G Redevelopment of a bad neighbor
site for residential development where
the current use has been the cause of
prolonged environmental conflict
and also supports the following planning
considerations appearance and design of
the development and materials proposed
improving highway safety improving
drainage and reducing flood risk
enhancing the character of the area
improving habitats for wildlife and
nature and having a positive impact on
the community thank you for your time
thank you very much just within your
time members do we have any questions
for our Parish counselor this evening
councilor hencher seraphin okay thank
you good evening
um are there any Residential Properties
either side of this site
[Music]
um where we were looking from the
crossroads towards Kyneton there are
some beyond the site on that side and
also on the opposite side of the main
Boundary Road as you head down in
towards Ox Hill
and there's no objection from them
those people they support the
application okay
home
hello um well from the documentation
we're given we're told that the housing
scheme would fail to relate to the rural
character of the area and the local
distinctiveness of the felden farmlands
character
um from what you said would you disagree
with that and say that the fits in the
buildings do fit with the area
yes I think the design is is very
um subtly done to to blend in with the
countryside and the and the way that the
buildings have been
um
utilizing the the sort of features that
are there already I think will fit in
really nicely
see you next
yeah good evening Council Houston this
is a question really about the issue of
it being a bad neighbor site there's a
couple of things I'd like to just pick
up on really it's the evidence for that
um you mentioned that there had been
when the wind is in a certain direction
you know the in the um the farm gives
off some odors and that's unpleasant can
you tell me whether or not you have any
record of reports to Environmental
Health in respect of of those odors and
the impact it's got on people nearby
I I don't I can't give you any data on
reports I have experienced it myself but
there's no I don't have a okay
so that's sort of anecdotal
um the other thing is about the um the
protests and the police presence and um
I can't remember exactly what I read
about the last time that happened
um what I need to establish from you is
is the sort of frequency of of those
disturbances and it unsettling the local
community I am under the impression that
some extra security measures have been
put onto the site I mean how often are
these protests happening are they still
happening have they stopped do we expect
them again
I would imagine there's always the risks
for as long as the business is there and
and
um
you know it's a very it can be a very
emotive subject and rearing animals for
food
um in terms of the the impact
um that
um main road from Stratford Stratford to
Banbury is very busy it's a 60 mile per
hour road with the crossroads there as
well
um when the protests have occurred the
protesters have been sort of around that
Junction so when you're trying to if
you're trying to draw in or out of the
roads to the The Villages either side
um as well you know it's getting past
those highway safety issue
um would be a particular concern to
Residents as well as you know
um seeing that situation with with armed
police you know sort of
um significant police presence in the
area is not normal for for our parishes
so okay unsettling for thank you council
at Houston thank you thank you any
further questions
no in which case thank you very much for
your contribution
okay our next speakers are Miranda
Rogers and Brian hobble
good evening uh so same pretty cool
you've got three minutes and I'll give
you a 30 second warning um I take it uh
Mr Rogers you're doing the speaking
Charlie good thank you very much uh in
which case uh when you're ready take it
away
okay good evening
as I speak I'd like you to watch the
images that are being shown that they
highlight the existing site and the
proposed Redevelopment so by way of
background this is a long-standing
intensive Pig rearing business operating
since the 1920s and bought by the
current applicant in 1996. it was highly
profitable with significant investment
until 2018 and succession was lined up
with the sun involved in the business
since 2017 the farm has been targeted by
activists not just a few people with
placards but to date over 40 organized
protests with multiple protesters in
addition there have been repeated
break-ins to the buildings causing harm
to the biosecurity of the site there
have been death threats to the operators
both verbal and non-verbal and a
significant slur campaign both locally
and nationally with false footage to
imply poor Animal Welfare most recently
in July 2023 activists climbed over
roofs dropped into the backyard and
prized the doors open animal Rebellion
has recently written to the National Pig
Association informing them that they are
going to be liberating pigs and taking
them to animal sanctuaries stating that
Hogwarts Farm is one of their main
targets
the result the loss of red tractor
status for the farm meaning very few
places to slaughter pigs a limited
market and a poorer price per Pig with
no likelihood of change fewer piglets
per sow on a lower survival rate the sun
has moved out of the industry and indeed
out of the country to avoid the
activists so there's no succession and
an inability to sell the farm the main
pig breeders have been approached and
have responded that the site is not
suitable due to animal rights protests
it's tainted and unlikely to ever be
suitable the solution the application
before you for the residential
Redevelopment of the site is the only
way the owner can see to move forwards
your officers have just suggested three
reasons for refusal so to consider each
in turn a lack of mechanism to deliver
off-site affordable housing and public
open space the applicant indicated from
the outset his agreement to enter into a
legal agreement to make appropriate
contributions the existing site no
longer viable for business purposes
we've presented evidence supported by
Alan Bloor and agricultural consultant
with over 35 years of experience in the
pig industry it's categoric the business
is unviable now that doesn't just mean
making a profit and will not improve in
the future no one will buy the business
due to the activists involvements
evidence submitted shows that no other
agricultural or commercial use or
Redevelopment provides a viable
alternative
10 houses in the countryside is country
to policy your policy team stated
the case for redevelopment is the
existing pig farm would need to be
clearly Justified based on the
provisions of the penultimate paragraph
of policy as-10 in line with that policy
The Proposal is fully Justified it will
offer significant benefits to the local
area and councilor littlewood is going
to outbound these to you and it's not
contrary to the overall strategy for the
district and on a landscape our
landscape appraisal concludes this
scheme will have no greater impact on
the landscape than the existing pig farm
and I hope from the images you've seen
you will agree
perfect timing thank you very much
members do we have any questions for the
agent or applicant
because the Keithley
thanks very much chair
um
yeah thanks good evening
um I've got a couple of questions really
about the the ongoing viability and um
I was able to look at some financial
information that you sent in on a
confidential basis so
um
what I could see as you've explained I
think is um
a fairly low operating return
and some uncertainty about higher
standards of welfare and such like but
what I'm interested to establish is
whether or not
if if the business is no longer viable
like any other business it could be any
business in in the country lots of
businesses for various external reasons
become less viable
whether or not the business could could
shift towards arable now you've made a
case in the report that the um
the arable business or if you turn the
the land over to arable farming it would
be
um it wouldn't really make a profit I go
I could see that but but 220 acres has
got has got an intrinsic value so it
could be wound up effectively as an
option could it what I'm interested to
know is if that was the case
um you know how many how many jobs are
affected because that's an important
consideration
um and what else what other what other
impacts would that have because if you
wound the business up 200. Keithley can
you please get some include your line of
questions so yeah I'm trying to get
across the questions and they're
complicated aren't they it's a difficult
assessment
um so could you answer the question
about the the winding up and the
viability of arable and also the
question about the the jobs at stake if
that was to happen okay
at the moment the land associated with
the farm is used to serve the feeding of
the pigs so all of the grain is served
to feed the pigs if you increase if you
lose the pigs
the amount of revenue from the arable
land and yes you could Farm it would not
give you a profit I don't if you want to
expand on that
there's 108 Acres
there's 108 Acres available which is not
a viable proposition on its own
um
So and I've got five employees uh of
which
um one of them is part-time
um and
um
one of them's going to retire Sean he's
um older than me
and and
the others
um
one of them will go back to Ukraine when
he gets a chance
and then I've got two local lands I've
been with me well two polish Lads been
with me for quite a long time I think
I'd be able to find some work doing
something else
I'd try something else if uh if the pig
farm went
or failing that they are experienced Pig
farmers and there would be jobs for them
in other pig farms it's anticipated if
that was their preference
oh yeah okay thanks very much
councilor Pemberton
thank you chair
um I've got two questions if I may and
they turn on
the question of the Bad Neighbor use
that was highlighted by the parish
council
um I wonder if you could help me
understand
uh how different your operation is from
any other Pig farming in Warwickshire in
terms of creating noxious smells how
different and uh
following on from that how many times
have there been complaints to or
investigations by environmental health
uh from the district council say in the
last five years in terms of noxious
smells so how different is it and how
many complaints have there been
there are only three Pig units in
Warwickshire of any consequence
um
I had
um a notice from uh
animal uh sorry environmental health
uh around pilotin priors and Clinton
Hersey going back some years ago
and I'm no longer allowed to spread in
that area
and so I refrain from that uh we I try
and move move the areas that we spread
on around so we don't upset too many
people for too long a period of time
um I'm aware that uh you know we affect
oxal for about 11 to 14 days a year in
the wind direction it can be quite
noxious yes I close the window myself so
um
and yeah
sorry
counselor Harvey thank you chairman I
had a related question for Miranda if
possible and the
councilor hewson
made the argument that
ass
10g was relevant the Bad Neighbor
argument you haven't Advanced that
argument why is that
it's a very good question
I think the neighbor objections are
better coming from the neighbors yes
there is a neighbor objection at the
time I wrote this application I wasn't
aware of how significant it was even
though I'd read some of the responses to
the initial application the more I get
into this the more I realize that it is
a problem although I'm well aware that
my client does his best to minimize any
adverse impact as any neighbor would
because there's been a pig farm here for
100 years
and this is his livelihood and he
doesn't want to damage the neighbors it
is inevitable that there will be
problems I think as members the option
is there to object to this and say it
complies with part G as a bad neighbor
development but I also think it complies
with penultimate paragraph of policy
as10 as an alternative it's on the next
page of the book if you're interested in
reading it um
it is
struggling to understand exactly because
it's not paragraph is relevant am I
allowed to go and point to it in his
book
yeah yes
to take guidance from our planning
officers to highlight that to uh to the
members I think it does say
um where it doesn't comply with any of
the specific criteria there are three
other criteria which can be applied and
that's the bit that I was focusing on
because I think that's where this fits
better but yes you can equally call this
a bad neighbor development
foreign
if it would help I can clarify the
paragraph referred to and I think
Miranda it's the penultimate one in the
blue box
so that says all of the types of
development or activity in the
countryside unless covered by specific
policy in the core strategy will need to
be fully Justified offer significant
benefits to the local area and not be
contrary to the overall development
strategy for the district
thank you any further questions for our
applicant
know in which case thank you very much
all right we'll now move on to our final
speaker who is a board member councilor
littlewood
good evening councilor
so you've got uh five minutes I'll give
you a 30 second warning as well and
otherwise when you're ready feel free to
start
thank you chair
um this site lies at the center of a
small dispersed group of properties
consisting of nine dwellings one
recently granted permission for two
modern barn conversions an equestrian
charity complex and a significant retail
and production facility
in evaluating applications officers must
apply the strict letter of policy and
recommend accordingly as understood
Richard Gardner in a con recent
conversation has confirmed that
committee members can consider other
information relevant to the application
and are empowered to conclude contrary
to that of the officer this is part of
democratic process in his right and
proper
in this case the business has become
non-viable because of severe activity by
a radical charity Beaver who have
pursued a campaign of intimidation
against the proprietor his family
employees over a period of years
because of this the action of Viva the
pig rearing business is no longer viable
as you've heard Red Tractor Mark is
removed sales channels closed and
therefore restraining trade the existing
site infrastructure is only suitable for
pig rearing and not for other livestock
Ventures
I am advised that the cost of excavation
to remove Subterranean structures and
renovation of the field in this re is in
the region of one million pounds against
which the expected revenue for grazing
over the area is around 50 pounds per
acre per annum we're talking about 2.4
hectares here I think the land is
considered as a green field because the
activity carried out was agricultural
the applicant has shown however that in
in some cases nationally such land has
been deemed degraded and permissions
granted in this case the blue clay
content of the spoil to be reinstated
would render this land unusable other
than for rough grazing a rational
conclusion is that this is now a
redundant industrial facility
as10 of the course strategy applies to
all parts of the district apart from
certain designated areas and Brownfield
sites and States all proposals will be
fairly assessed against the principles
of sustainable development including
minimizing impact on the local character
of the landscape communities and
environmental features minimize the
impact of the occupiers and users of
existing properties avoid a level of
increase in traffic on Rural roads
harmful to the local area
and make provision for sustainable forms
of Transport prioritize reuse and bra of
Brownfield sites and existing buildings
in the penultimate paragraph of cs10
provide it provides for flexibility to
consider all applications on their Merit
the proposed scheme exhibits high
quality design cs9 using a variety of
materials and styles giving the
appearance of a traditional farmyard and
buildings that will enhance the site and
fit well into the landscape as10
substantially so sustainability tests
are met by this application and it will
enhance the visual character of the site
from a fortified industrial complex to a
rural scene
as required by the
penultimate paragraph of the policy The
Proposal will offer significant benefits
to the local area with a reduction in
transport movements particularly of hgvs
and slurry tankers a reduction of odor
and noise nuisance to the surrounding
settlement
a lowering of carbon emissions the
removal of activists from the locality
which causes distress to local people
and necessarily engages the police and
the scheme will provide some 275 000
toward affordable housing in the
accountancy
it will also provide a high quality
residential environment based on
self-sufficient sustainability energy
models in mitigating climate change by
utilizing ground Source energy
harvesting solar energy domestic wind
power and a highest standard of building
design and imaginative Landscaping
chair this is an unusual application
brought about by circumstances beyond
the control of the applicant by an
agency that has intimidated a lawful
business employing local people with no
interest in the local economy or the
mental and financial well-being of the
residents it is outside any situation
that the drafting of the core strategy
could have imagined
this scheme will enhance the character
of the area and to the benefit of the
residents and sorry beg your pardon and
to the benefit of the residents and the
environment and complies with policies
of the development plan is supported by
Pilot and Hersey and Oxo parish councils
as well as 32 residents some of which
are in close proximity to the properties
there are no objections from statutory
bodies or third parties other than cpre
and I urge the committee to support this
application with conditions for the
benefit of the local community thank you
thank you very much councilor very uh
perfect timing members do we have any
questions for our award member
councilor Harvey
councilor would um the officer in her
report describes this site as an still
to be considered an agricultural
operation you describe it as either a
redundant industrial facility or a
fortified industrial complex how would
you reconcile those
thank you councilor Harvey yes
um that's a very good point you raise
um if you actually travel the road
you'll see that the entry all the
entrances and the the uh the uh Outer
Perimeter of the uh of the site is
guarded with high relatively High uh
fencing and barbed wire Etc to stop uh
trespass and
um militants uh getting into the site
for their own safety as much as anything
else it is ugly it doesn't look like a
farm it looks like a um an industrial
site as it stands now and removing of
those
um
visual impacts will enhance and return
the site to look like it should in a
rural environment it will go back to a a
a Countryside rather than a an
industrial complex with regards to your
second question with regard
the building itself is not you've just
seen the surface uh pictures
um of the uh of the facility underneath
that there are several meters of uh
concrete runways for removal of slurry
Etc it's quite it goes down some several
meters so
um this can't be used for any other
livestock operation I am informed so it
could not be passed on for example to
sheep farming
and so I resolve your the the the
situation with those comments
any further questions for our Ward
member
in which case thank you very much for
your time councilor littlewood thank you
chair okay
um we're now moving on to points of
clarification for our officer members do
we have any uh councilor Harvey
um could the officer please
um describe to to councilors present uh
in simple terms if possible what in
planning terms constitutes a bad
neighborhood site and what evidence
would the committee need to be presented
what sort of evidence which would
describe or illustrate a bad
neighborhood site please
um Bad Neighbor site
um the the reference occurs in policy
as10 and it occurs as an exception to
the otherwise restrictive housing
policies in the district an is-10g
allows the Redevelopment of a bad
neighbor site for residential
development where the current use has
been the cause of prolonged
environmental conflict
and then if you go further into the
policy there's a section starting on
page 196 called development management
considerations
and number eight of those
explains what part G the exception G is
aimed at
and it says a documented history of
environmental conflict will be required
to accompany a planning application to
seek to justify Redevelopment scheme
and in this case we haven't had that
so I did use from that then you are
absolutely Rock Solid certain that in
your terms this is not a bad neighbor
side
that's correct yes
that's the Pemberton
thank you chair
um if I could follow on
the line about Bad Bad Neighbor sites
just so I can get some clarity in my own
mind and hopefully for the rest of the
committee
am I correct in my understanding that
in terms of a bad neighbor site in
planning terms it's the operation of the
site and if the site operates
as a pig farm should operate that's the
element that needs to be considered as
far as any bad neighbor element is
concerned as opposed to the impact of
external factors in this case protesters
and the re and the response of the
Police Service to protesters so if we
are considering Bad Neighbor
do we have to consider solely the
operation of the site as a pig farm
or can we at all consider
the additional impact that is
detrimental
um and I take the point that there is no
that there are no environmental uh
reports but in the broader context of
Bad Neighbor to what extent in planning
terms can we take into account if at all
the question of the ongoing protests and
Police Service involvement and its
impact on the community
I don't think it arises in this case but
theoretically it could be that protests
are prolonged and noisy and could cause
rise to environmental health complaints
so there could be a circumstance under
as-10 where it would be allowable
because of that but that hasn't Arisen
in this case
is that is that because there's no
documentary evidence of the complaints
having been made or is or is that a
as you've heard from the applicant there
is documentary evidence but that was
resolved around not spreading that
there's no other
Apostle Harvey again
um could I ask the case officer about
her description of this site as an
agricultural operation and clearly there
have been contributions this evening
which don't see it that way is has
anything been said which
shakes your understanding of what an
agriculture whether agricultural
operation is the correct description in
planning terms
of course say the site is an
agricultural enterprise as a pig rearing
Enterprise and due to that reason we
would consider it as an agricultural use
whilst it is intensive in terms of an
agricultural use it is still classified
in planning terms and in the nppf as
being an agricultural youth which is
therefore a Greenfield site
Council Keithley yeah thanks chairman
could I ask the planning officer if if
he could just expand on the the
definition of environmental conflict
because we've just heard that um in that
context it was about muck spreading I
want to know whether or not
environmental conflict conflict would
include
activists police things like local
nuisance and hgvs
as I said in my previous response it
could do but that's why it's important
to have documentary evidence because on
one end of the scale you could have one
phone call saying there's some noise
please investigate I wouldn't say that
would constitute environmental conflict
but on the other hand of the scale you
could have as the policy requires a
prolonged series of complaints to
environmental health which have been
followed up with noise abatement notices
or other action formal action that has
gone unresolved to the point that the
site is drawn to a bit of phrasal
problem site that's what the Bad
Neighbor policy is aimed at finding a
new use for a site where unresolved
conflict over a long period of time
um has occurred and therefore the
planning system is there to find a
better use to resolve that but but as
I've said previously this site isn't in
that category
how's the Parry
thank you chair and one with the
officers can give some indication of
weight that we should be giving to this
penultimate paragraph that is has been
highlighted
by the applicant's agent all other types
of development or activity in the
countryside the ward member
clarified and it's quite clear that this
is a very unusual situation where we've
got
protesters and the situation with the
pig farm
um and I would just welcome some
additional guidance as to what weight we
should be placing on that penultimate
paragraph to as10 please
so in terms of the way officers have
assessed this if I can um
draw you back to the top of page 33
um there are a couple of paragraphs
there which relate to that part of
policy as10
which can in certain circumstances
justify development in the open
Countryside but that would be that would
need to be fully Justified offer
significant benefits to the local area
and not be countries the overall
development strategy for the district
so the applicant has submitted some
justification to try and demonstrate how
the development would fit that part of
as10 which we have considered however
the arguments that they have put forward
are predominantly personal and we do not
consider that they would fully justify
or offer significant benefits the local
area and ultimately are not in
accordance with the overall development
plan for the area because of the loss of
the viable business and then the 10
dwellings in the open Countryside as
well
councilor Harvey
thank you German
um
I have a real problem
the um
the agent has referred to a consultant's
report which concludes that this is not
a viable operation
the council has commissioned an
alternative source of information which
says that non-viable or paraphrasing
non-viability has not been established
we have
two bits of advice or two bits of
evidence which are pointing exactly the
opposite directions as the officer got
any advice for us are we evaluate and
reconcile those two
say the council's independent
agricultural consultant has assessed the
information that's been submitted by the
applicant so that includes some of the
financial information
to try and demonstrate that the business
is not viable
the council's agricultural consultant
has considered all that information and
still considers that the business is
viable
and moving forward that it still would
show as a viable business as well
um
perhaps the other things about the the
the
viability the agricultural consultant
appointed by the council house raised
um issues with the submitted report in
terms of
um areas and that they're on page 29 to
31 of your reports areas that more
information would be needed
for example
um
Center of page 29
no accounts or information is extended
profit achieved during the early period
of this operation have been provided
um
and then further down page 29
um that they've looked at the the
figures and show a significant profit
after all costs
um
the other thing
they've looked at is importantly Pig
prices which have gone up recently so
some of the
um where losses have occurred could be
down to that in part
um but we're comfortable as officers
that are independent agricultural
consultant has looked at all the
relevant stuff and has brought their
experience to bear and their expertise
to bear and we're comfortable with the
way they've advised us
castle of Parry next
thank you
um with regard to the council's
independent consultant review
um did that take into any account the
investment
um in the farm that would need to be
done to continue its viability
because clearly looking at the
um
the setup and the formula that would be
clear clearly
need over the next few years that
significant investment would be would be
required did the Consultants report
consider that as part of his overall or
her overall assessment
I think we're entitled to assume that
they have taken into account what
they've been presented with
and any investments in the future they
would have taken into account
come into that conclusion that that it
is viable going forward
councilor Keithley
thank you chair uh this is just
following on from councilor Paris
question because I read the fox
submission in response to the applicants
report and I you know if you can help me
understand
um I recollect that I read that the fox
report towards the end commented on the
future viability in respect of things
like additional security costs going
forward higher Animal Welfare standards
and the investment that councilor Parry
made reference to it can I mean we don't
have the fox report in front of us can
you can you just clarify exactly what
was said towards the end of that report
in respect of the future viability of
this Farm
isn't it all right
all right um yeah the the conclusions on
viability uh in section five
um
the independent consultant concludes
overall the business appears to be
producing a healthy profit and despite
the challenging circumstances and
uncertain future one cannot say for sure
that the farm will not continue to be
profitable for some time to come
councilor Parry chair is it possible to
recall the applicant to ask some
specific questions about
in investment and um on the going
viability of of the farm I would find
that really quite helpful
is that possible I'm
I'm reticent to to have that form any
sort of open discussion I'm happy to
take have them back for very specific
points of fact
two seconds
it has to be for a point of
clarification
on a disputed fact
if you're if you have a question that
that would be satisfied by their
involvement then I I'm happy for them to
come up for that purpose but it has to
be very concise and discreet what you're
going to ask for for that purpose if you
understand
no I do totally understand I just think
it would be helpful to know
um
what investment plans would be required
for the to carry on future
over the next five years as a going
concern
because clearly clearly if the farm has
has
you know they can see no no business
future in it they won't have put much
money into the farm over the last year
or two and therefore in addition
whilst whilst The Profit might look
fairly
certainly better than it is than it than
it would be if they hadn't actually
invested in materials in the actual Farm
I think it's quite important for us
we're making very serious decisions on
the future viability of this Farm I
think if I would find it very helpful to
know what levels of investment will be
required on a going on a going forward
concern for this to be viable
no thank you councilor pemberton's
looking either eager to
um
councilor Perry I absolutely understand
I think our difficulty is we're going to
get into the Realms of
an applicant who's going to do off on
the Fly
tell you what his investment plans may
or may not be and
there's no evidence for that I
understand where you want to go with it
but I'm not sure how we're going to be
able to
validate that and if he if we can
understand that
I understand why we would want to have
that but I'm just not sure
and I'm just asking for some guidance
here particularly from the legal officer
as to how we're going to introduce
evidence about investment or otherwise
in this particular Forum I just I I
understand and I can I can go along with
it I just want to make sure that we're
on the the right side of it that's all
and perhaps a legal officer might help
thank you
I'm happy to take
some yeah we're just getting some more
information from our league off so we'll
see where we go
um in the meantime there are there any
further points of clarification
councilor Keithley yeah I would like to
ask the um planning officer again about
the fox report and I turn back to what
councilor Harvey said that we were
struggling to see uh to reconcile the
differences in
um the um the reports and the appraisals
from the applicants consultant to the
fox consultant and I asked you if the
issue of
um the security aspect the cost of
security the costs of higher Animal
Welfare standards environmental
standards and also the issue of the
movement of of the animals to abattoirs
was likely to impact the future
viability and I'm confident that I've
read that in the fox report and I'd just
like a confirmation that those comments
are reflected in that report because
when you've read the final paragraph you
didn't answer that specific question
that I had
unconfident I've seen them in that and
I'm confident that that final paragraph
that talks about challenging
circumstances reflects that but if you
want me to be give a specific answer on
all those things being taken account of
I'd have to look at the report to find
specific reference to them to confirm
for you thank you it's enough that you
recognize that those particular issues
were reflected in that report and he
referred to those as challenging
circumstances thank you
chairman could I just offer a gun in
relation to the point that counselor
Keith has just raised
um I have got a copy of the fox report
in front of me and there is a paragraph
which deals with the cost of the
business going in the future and there
is a reference to the additional costs
which the the value has acknowledged and
in in coming to his View
I could read it out too if you if I if I
was permitted but I I gather just
confidential information
thank you um Amy has something to
contribute
so I think first just to address I think
it was councilor Perry's question about
inviting the applicant back so the
chairman does have authority to invite
an individual to speak again but it is
only to clarify a fact
um so you know sort of in terms of
introducing new things if it's not
something that's already been questioned
and so just just keep that one in mind
and that'll be the chair's discretion in
terms of councilor Pemberton
um
yes so if if I think we have to go off
what's been assessed so far you know and
the evidence that's been provided has
been independently assessed so to
introduce something now hasn't been
assessed
um so we wouldn't have any answer to
that
okay thank you uh on on that basis I'm
not going to ask them back because I
think we ultimately we need our officers
to be able to respond to things and they
have been able to do so in a timely
manner which led us to here but I do
appreciate the the sentiment of your
quest thank you are there any further
points of clarification
I was passing him
um are we allowed to accept the
arguments saying that it's not viable
and and over overall this independent
are we allowed to in planning terms do
that
um yes you have a report from you from
Alan Bloor the applicants consultant
that says the K that the farm isn't
viable so if you give that more weight
than the council's consultant then
you're entitled to conclude implanting
terms at the site isn't that business
isn't viable
okay okay any further points
clarification okay in which case we can
move to the debate
who would like to start
counselor homes
yeah so my thoughts are so working
through the ostriches recommendation
starting with part two I think we were
shown quite well that the proposals
don't contradict cs9 in the design and
distinctiveness of of the um of the
proposed development I think it seems
very sympathetic to the rural
surroundings and backed up by the
opinions of the parish councilor who who
lives in the area
um and I don't think I'm convinced that
CS5 that it's an unacceptable visual
impacts on the rural environment I don't
think that either
um
I'd I'd appreciate if someone maybe
wants to step in to tackle the um as10
aspects but those are my immediate forms
from that first bit
thank you very much
who would like to speak next
couple of passing them
yeah I see it as a very difficult sort
of decision but I think I I accept the
arguments that it's unviable in terms of
not just economically but
environmentally to carry on with this
farm and
um it should really be treated as a
Brownfield site in which case it's a
good you know be a reasonable
development for that site
councilor Harvey
um
my start point is that this is in effect
an application to build 10 houses in the
open Countryside
this is an agricultural operation as
defined by planning considerations
it in order to
we don't allow
a building of houses in the open
Countryside by as-10 unless one of the
gateways can be satisfied the only
Gateway that might be applicable
is the Bad Neighbor site argument and
we've had that confirmed from the
officers that that does not apply
I think in essence it's it's as simple
as that and I think that the the
question of why the application is being
raised is either viability or
non-viability of the operation as a as a
pig pig farm
is almost secondary in my terms
um I I I sympathize uh with Mr hogwill
because
the difficulties he finds himself in are
due to the actions of others
but he's trying to solve his problem by
going through a planning application
route and
whilst that gives rise to the reason for
the application it doesn't justify the
application set against policy criteria
um if we for argument's sake if we put
the viability non-viability argument on
one side just put it on one side
and let's assume that that it is
non-viable for the sake of the argument
um that would have to be fully Justified
which clearly it isn't fully Justified
because there's argument about it in
different experts take different points
of view it would have to offer
significant benefits to the local area
well I think the argument on that goes
two ways because one could say the the
odor argument although pig farms in
rural areas is Not Unusual
I live in a rural area myself and I we
suffer from Chicken menu of smells but
by the by
um but there are local there are local
benefits to be had in that sense
environmental uh quality of air and so
on but there's also disbenefits of
impact on landscape Etc
but the third leg is not to be contrary
to overall development strategy for the
district well this application clearly
is contrary to to who are our overall
strategy for the for the distribution of
of houses this is this is not in a
built-up area it's not in a limited
service Village it's it's out in the
open
unarguably it's not adjacent to a
built-up area boundary it is unarguably
in the open Countryside
and as10 applies and it doesn't satisfy
any other gateways of as10
so
I I really don't while I I do sympathize
with the business problem that Mr
hobbill has I don't see that this that
this application is the right way in
planning terms I didn't see how I can
support it
I'll be interested to hear what others
say and think but currently I would be
in very inclined to accept the officer's
recommendation
would you say that's a proposal
I would wait for the debate from
contributions from others before going
that far
very good thank you
um I'll go to
um
house Pemberton in a second but I would
like to say that I actually completely
agree with them what councilor Harvey's
just said
um on the basis that I I accept that
there are incredibly hard times for this
business but that doesn't justify
building housing in this location in
this way and I think that's the policy
direction that we have
on that basis Council Harvey's been very
eloquent in in the way that you put it I
will make a proposal to go along with
the counselors uh sorry with the
officer's recommendation so I will seek
a second as I said though I'll now go to
counselor Pemberton
thank you
chair and I shall try to
avoid the traditional trap of uh
repeating what a an earlier speaker has
said so I'll try and build on that
um
but I do agree that this is
fundamentally a housing application in
the middle of the countryside
I absolutely understand and sympathize
with
the views of residents the views of the
parish council
that
recent events
um
Allied to this site I mean this is a
really difficult place to live at the
moment
um in terms of protesters Police Service
involvement
and it's a harsh thing to say but it's
not the planning it's not the role of
the planning system
to manage lawful public protest
the business finds itself in challenging
circumstances because of changes it
cannot secure Red Tractor Assurance for
whatever reason
its markets are not entirely closed off
to it
there is evidence that it is continuing
to trade
albeit that it's difficult
there is no evidence that
the site
in of itself operates in any other way
or creates any greater detrimental harm
by virtue of its own operation as
distinguished from the
activities of protesters and the
consummate the concurrent involvement of
the police service and all that that
brings with it
taking that aside it is on the face of
it no different to any other
pig farm operation in Warwickshire or
any other County for that matter
and
therefore I am not persuaded by The Bad
Neighbor argument
because I think that it I think it's a
stretch argument to say that the stuff
that goes around it creates it as a bad
neighbor I think the first principle is
the operation of the site
um that might be for others to test at
appeal but that's my rationale at this
point
I then come to
the evidence that we have those of us
who've requested it and I'm assuming
we've all requested it the confidential
information around the viability
um
this is not burning platform this
business it's got challenges but it's
got
some viability and it has some options
they're not easy options but it has
options it is far from an unviable
business based on the evidence that I've
seen and I am also minded to consider
what the applicant's expert themselves
say at section 3.13 of the applicants
expert report and I'm not sure the
extent to which I can quote from it
because it's a confidential
I'm not going to quote for it yeah
that's right I knew I knew what the
answer was it's okay but that is
absolutely clear in terms of it talks
about a strategy rather than a need
there are other options for this
business so overall I am not minded that
there is a sufficient evidence base
that the business is unviable
I see nothing
um in our in the
the council's own expert
report
that is fundamentally flawed and that
would enable me as a decision maker to
discard it
and with all of that in mind and noting
that it is undoubtedly unpopular as far
as the the local residents are concerned
I am prepared to back uh chair and
second a recommendation to uh to to
support the officer's recommendation
um policy is not engaged this is housed
in the in the open Countryside
there are not enough tests they've not
got over the bar
um
and I don't see that we should
rationally come to a different decision
than the last time this application was
heard so I will be support I will be
seconding a recommendation to Grant
refuse
or even to refuse it's been a long day
thank you counselor Pemberton would
anyone else like to speak on this item
councilor homes again
I'd strongly disagree I think although
it's in the open Countryside it would be
lazy not to take into account the nature
of the sites
um itself it's not open Fields
um whatsoever and I think going back to
as10 I think it's common sense that this
development will offer substantial
benefits to to the local community and
um we can't ignore that and I think that
we should give more weight to that than
the opposing arguments so I'd like to
propose um that we accept the
application
okay thank you uh I believe that
councilor Perry was there
thank you I just want to emphasize that
I do sympathize hugely with the
applicant and I hope
um he appreciates we've actually tried
to look at every possible angle
um but that evidence wasn't forthcoming
um unfortunately on this occasion
um so I will be going with the officer's
recommendation to refuse
um and on the basis so many solar Farms
keep getting
um approved
um who I won't say that could be another
route but um there is some land there
and I'll leave it at that
thank you any further speakers councilor
Andrew serif yeah thank you
um as it's
been said it's agricultural well it's
much to me it's more Industrial
and Industrial farming creates a problem
against climate change
um
although I'm not fully happy with the
expensive houses on this site they they
do blend in well and um
far better
aesthetically
than the pig farm
I know I would be struggling for a
planning reason but um
I'm not happy
going against the application
because I think he would enhance the
countryside anyway thank you
okay thank you Council Fleming
I'll just pop in at the end
um
for me agriculture raising the pigs is
little half rain creep sheds all over a
field in the pigs are running free if
you're going to cram everything into to
crates to farrowing pens and whatever
within those big green buildings
that's industrial that's not agriculture
you know and and I think that's one of
the things that you have to look at and
I can't
I can't reconcile myself in the fact
that planning law means we should leave
ugly green sheds that smell really bad
or put some houses in the same place so
that's the bit I'm struggling with the
the preference to keep that farm as it
is
against having 10 modern houses and
whatever that goes with them
I'm finding that very very difficult to
reconcile myself with so so from that
perspective
I'm just using what I would say is
somebody stepping outside the planning
thing really but why would I want to
live next to a pig farm when I can have
10 houses why would the council back not
having those 10 houses
um the viability thing what do we do if
the guy can't make any money do we wait
till he goes bust and then what's going
to happen to the site then I don't know
but all of these things don't sit with
me well enough that I can back the
officer's recommendation so that's all I
wanted to say
okay thank you councilor Fleming
any further speakers yeah
thank you chairman uh well like many
others I'm thinking I'm finding this
very difficult
um it does feel like housing an open
Countryside which I think is against our
policies
but I did look at the viability
assessment in great detail and um I can
see that this business is going to find
it extremely challenging going forward
um because of the nature of the the
activists actions not that that's really
a planning issue but you can't you can't
take away the fact that that is
affecting people in the local
environment and the local neighborhood
they're feeling that
um they've also got a lot of hcvs to
deal with
um the farm I think will be struggling
going forward as I said a little look in
great detail about that I think that I
can see that in terms of viability that
argument that cs22 could be satisfied
and in terms of the definition of a bad
neighbor site okay we're not entirely
clear on it
um it's about long-term environmental
conflicts
but I think it's more than just muck
spreading on fields I think
environmental conflicts can cover a
number of different things and I think
that we're potentially going to see more
of that going forward which is going to
affect the parish councils and the the
local communities so I'm leaning towards
um move going away from the officer's
recommendation to um to accepting that
on this particular occasion
it might be better to accept that we
have some houses there instead of an
industrial type agricultural unit
thank you very much councilor Harvey can
I invite those councilors who are
thinking of going against the officer's
recommendation
to identify what what part of as10 which
Gateway that that provides for building
houses in the open Countryside that they
are going to cite as the basis for their
View
and if they can't are they really saying
that in the vernacular bugger policy I'm
going to vote for it in any case
lahomes I'd refer back to the
developmental office substantial
benefits to the local area and and I use
that as the basis for
um for going for the application
just to clarify if members are looking
at that penultimate paragraph of as10
it's not on or it's an and an and so
there's three things that have to be met
it has to be fully Justified
it has to offer significant benefits the
local area and not be contrary to the
development plan
right
um
I I can appreciate the sense of feeling
on this and the the divisiveness of it
um in a number of ways Uh current we
have a proposal and a seconder to go
along with the officer's recommendations
I am aware we have a proposal for going
against that although I am not currently
convinced of the reasoning behind that
in policy
current we have to go for the proposal
that was seconded first
I'm now going to move to the vote on
that item
right
so the proposal is to go along with the
officer's recommendation to refuse for
the reason stated in the report and the
update sheet
can I see all those in favor
five
and those opposed
four one two three five five five well
it's a Thai vote and as the chairman I
have the casting vote in which case the
application is refused
therefore committee resolves to refuse
application
23-00518 ful
right that was quite a heavy one so I'm
going to give everyone a two minute
Comfort break thank you
I was doing your planning manager
of it
right um
ready so it's application 23
01529 out part of the garden old garden
house Morton paddocks uh Morton moral
uh Victoria's are presenting officer
when you're ready take it away
consent for one self-build and custom
dwelling and is identified by the black
dot on the map
the site is located within Morton
paddocks which is an all of the
settlement
it's also within the felden Parkland
special landscape area
this plan shows the site outlined in red
which is part of the rear Garden of old
garden house
the site also includes a linear strip of
side Garden which will be to create a
new vehicular access from Wells Born
Road to the north
on this slide I've roughly indicated the
extent of the site in red you can see
more clearly how the site relates to Old
garden house to the north and how the
site would be enclosed by residential
development on all four boundaries
the new access would run parallel with
the access for the property to the South
these are the site photos and image one
is a view taken with within the site
looking towards the rear of the site to
the southwest South East
the brick boundary wall marks the rear
of white acre
photo number two is taken within the
site looking back towards our garden
house you can see how the site is
currently in use to residential Garden
this is the street view image shown the
hose dwelling in white and its existing
access the new proposed access is to go
between the two accesses near to where
the telegraph pole is here
this is the approximate location of the
proposed access in a bit more detail
which would be in between the two
existing accesses
in summary offices have recommended
refusal for the reason within the report
the only update is the general update
regarding the mppf and this concludes my
presentation thank you chairman
thank you very much our first speaker is
counselor Ann Perry more than moral
Parish Council
good evening councilor
this current juncture you have three
minutes
thank you chair I'll give you a 30
second warning uh I don't think I should
need it you're right without okay
Charlie good or whenever you're ready
thank you
Parish Council of Morton moral Parish
Council I can confirm that the PC is
pleased to support this application as
it causes no significant harm and there
is no differentiation between this
application and planning permission for
the local needs dwelling approved in
March this year apart from the section
106 agreement
so there is no difference to the
footprint of size or size of the
dwelling they are mirror images of each
other in terms of built form
the parish will not benefit or gain from
sale payments as the applicant would be
still exempt from both the local needs
dwelling or this self and custom build
application as the local needs building
dwelling would be self-built
there have been no objections raised by
any Villages across the parish and no
objections from statutory consulties
either
as a self-built custom build dwelling
this would help to contribute towards
SDC shortfall and therefore carries more
weight than a local needs dwelling
so in essence this is just a change in
planning classification that should be
given more weight than is attributed to
in the officer's report
in addition there is no precedent been
set as there is a permission already
granted for a local needs dwelling which
carries the Restriction of having to
market the property in the first
instance to prospective prospective
purchases with a local connection to
Morton moral for for 12 weeks
this restriction is consequently
reducing the number of mortgage products
available by lenders to the applicant in
view of the current financial crisis
thank you members
thank you very much councilor well
within your time members do we have any
questions for our Parish counselor
copper and seraphim no thank you all
right
um
is this a genuine self-built house or
somebody living in the village yes it is
the applicant actually lives in Old
garden house and and wants to build this
single story in the garden
um for themselves
um it is purely for themselves
um which is why they applied for a local
dwelling and the the application for the
local dwelling was first applied in 2021
when we were just in the middle of covid
and there were the financial problems
hadn't really emerged
um and following they got full
permission in March this year and then
looking at close closely at the section
and exploring
um mortgage products and that sort of
thing because of the restrictions
applied with the local needs dwelling
and in The Current financial crisis
there are less products available for
the applicant so in either way their
mirror images it the applicant would be
building for themselves as a self-build
for the local needs dwelling anyway so
and and then this dwelling would would
obviously contribute towards the
self-build register
Council Perry
the officer's recommendation makes the
point that the development proposed
doesn't constitute any of the types of
developments supported in the principle
by policy as10
um how would you respond to that
conclusion
sorry councilor Harvey can you repeat
that
sure the officer has concluded that
development doesn't constitute any of
the development types supported in
principle by policy as10 I'm just asking
how you would how you respond to that
point
my view is that this self-built dwelling
carries more significant weight from a
legal perspective because it actually
adds to the self-build shortfall which
should therefore carry more significant
weight
than other policies
councilor Pemberton
thank you chairman councilor Parry is
there a
housing needs survey or any other
evidence base that talks about the
requirement for local needs
in place
yes I can confirm
um there was a housing needs survey
undertaken in 2021 which identified the
need for three for single story
um single-story three-bedroom dwellings
to date we've only had one
well in fact it's two because the local
needs counts for for one of them which
was a um a key rationale why it it got
the local needs because of the housing
needs survey but the full Planning
Commission for that only only came
through in March this year
any further questions
no in which case thank you very much
okay uh we now move on to our next
speakers who are Jane Cashmore and Karen
Marshall
good evening
um so you've got three minutes
um I take it uh Miss Cashmore you're
doing the speaking then therefore uh
questions jolly good um yeah so when
you're ready I'll know I'll give you a
30 second one thank you good evening
thank you for the opportunity of
speaking outline permission is sought
for a single self-build custom build
dwelling SCB
the council is required to make a
decision in line with the development
plan unless material considerations
indicate otherwise
in this case there are material
considerations which justify the grant
of this planning application
I respectfully disagree with your
office's recommendation and I'll explain
the three reasons why
firstly the fallback your officer
accepts that the existing permission on
the site for a local needs dwelling is a
fallback position and a material
consideration in the determination of
the application
the weight to give to a material
consideration is a matter for the
decision taker so you don't have to
follow your officer's opinion
your officer is of the view that the
proposed SCB is more harmful than the
fallback
my opinion differs what is key here is
that the proposed SCB will go towards
fulfilling a legal Duty the council have
to provide for such dwellings and there
is a shortfall
therefore I consider that greater weight
should be given to fulfilling a legal
Duty and therefore the proposed SCB
compared to the fallback the proposed
SCB is therefore preferable
the second reason is that your officer
states that the development is contrary
to CS 1516 and as10 even though the
officer has already confirmed that none
of these policies reference SCB so
should only carry moderate weight
this waiting is overlooked in the
conclusions and reason for refusal
in any event these policies are about
the balanced dispersal of Housing
Development
planning permission already exists on
site for a single dwelling and there
would be no gain in dwellings over and
above that already proved at Autumn
paddocks
there is no material difference in the
erection of an SCB versus a local needs
dwelling in vocational sustainability
terms
thirdly the lack of compliance with the
emerging sap is not determinative and
appeals indicate it should only carry
limited weight
in summary the council is required to
make a decision in line with the
development plan and less material
considerations indicate otherwise the
development plan doesn't cover SCB
policies cs1516 and as10 should only
carry moderate weight at best
as the report sets out there is
considerable expectation and
justification for taking a positive
approach to SCB
the legal duty to provide for SCB and
the council shortfall should carry
significant positive weight
Additionally the fallback and preference
of the full preference of the proposed
SCB over the fallback outweighs any
limited policy conflict you may consider
exists and justifies the grant of
planning permission
there should be no concerns about
precedent if you grant this application
the site is unique based on the fallback
and the fact that there are entries on
the self-build register citing Morton
paddocks thank you for listening
bang on three minutes thank you very
much members do we have any questions
for our applicant or agent
doesn't look like it in which case I
believe that's everything thank you very
much
all right so we now move to our final
speaker who is our award member
good evening councilor Perry
councilor you have five minutes
uh are happy again to give you a 30
second warning otherwise
you see I wear lots of hats
members this is essentially a case for
the need of common sense to apply
regarding this application the reasons
being it provides exactly the same
footprint and scale of the existing
permission for a local needs dwelling
there are no objections from Villages or
statutory consultees and in a nutshell
it is just a change in its planning
classification which would benefit SDC
shortfall and legal requirement to
provide a supply of self-build dwellings
it is therefore disappointing that not
more weight has been given to this valid
point in the officer's report
for those of you concerned about a
precedent being set there are no worries
here either because there is an existing
planning permission for a local needs
dwelling on exactly the same plot at
exactly the same size and scale and
access
you are all aware of the loophole in the
self-building custom build act which is
prompting developers to seize upon plots
of land to secure 10 plus plots but this
is not one of them I can also advise
that the applicant's planning permission
for the local needs dwelling commenced
in 2021 when the financial climate was
in a totally different era and we were
expering lockdowns due to the covid
pandemic so totally different to that in
March this year when full planning
permission was granted
today's property Market is facing a fall
in-house prices and valuations and
consequently mortgage lenders have
become far more cautious and are
applying stricter criteria plus of
course construction costs have increased
significantly this means there are far
less mortgage products available to the
applicant than there were back in 2021
and interest rates have increased from
0.1 percent to 5.25 which is the highest
level in over 15 years so to iterate the
material planning reasons to Grant
permission are very clear there is no
significant harm to charging changing
the planning classification to
self-build custom build in view of the
current fallback situation of a local
needs dwelling planning permission
fulfills the legal obligation that SDC
has for self-built custom build
dwellings and this application reduces
the current shortfall and is therefore
more preferable to the fallback position
and greater wage should be given in this
respect there is no loss in sell
payments to SDC or mmpc there is no
precedent being set for self-built
custom Bill dwelling in this location
because of the fallback position the
Parish of moral is an
lsv4 local village with a requirement to
build a minimum of 32 new dwellings
within the core strategy period and to
date planning permissions have only been
secured for 12 new dwellings which
includes the local needs dwelling
thank you members
thank you very much members any
questions for our award member
no in which case thank you very much
Council Perry
okay when I move on to points of
clarification from our officers members
do we have any what's clarification
councilor Harvey I could ask the officer
in coming to her conclusion and
recommendation could she
explain what elements of this
application she gave what weight
because I as I understand it
this decision will depend upon our
interpretation and what weight we give
to particular elements and I'd be
interested to know
um how the officer came to her
conclusion
um just an answer to a question
um
I'm going to answer I'm going to answer
it rather than Victorious simply because
it's in my writing and it would be
harder to read
um not say Victoria doesn't know the the
waiting that she's given but the waiting
is on the one hand you've got the
shortfall in self-build that's given
significant weight
but on the other hand you've got the
core strategy and you've got core
strategy policy cs15 and as10 which have
moderate weight because they didn't
foresee the self-build ACT
but you've also got against the
application the emerging sap
which is all we have in terms of
locational criteria for myself build go
that has limited weight
uh the fallback we consider to be
neutral in that balancing act so
if you're looking at that those are the
weightings that we've given to the
different issues if that helps
thank you very good counselor Keithley
thank you
um could you just confirm
um
for me please the the applicant's agent
said that there were self and custom
built entries on the register for Morton
paddocks
is that correct
um thank you um I don't have those
figures
um with me up to date
um but I am aware that the
um the self-build is a district-wide
need
okay thanks
for the parts clarification
um
the the
um the plot looks as if it's surrounded
by dwellings is there any reason why
it's outside the built up boundary
um I have concluded in the report that
it's within the physical confines but
that it's in all of the settlement
rather than a local service Village and
it's the local service Village which is
referred to in the emerging site
allocations plan
all right so it's not and so yeah so to
clarify it's not a service it's not in
the service Village to clarify it's in
all other settlement rather than Alexa
yeah
thank you any further points of
clarification
so in which case we can move to the
debate who'd like to start
on stirring councilad and
um thank you chair uh I'll be honest I
can't see any harm in changing the
classification at all
um if it's going to be the same
that's kind of the conclusion that I've
I've come to with with mind of the
planning balance I mean I'll leave it
there everyone see if anyone follows on
with anything more interesting
thank you counselor Adam and lightning
um
nobody else wants to go okay
as virtually this dwelling has been
granted previously with conditions I
don't see any any difference in
I'm all in favor of a true self-built
house for people to live in what they
want thank you thank you very much
believe Richard had something he wanted
to contribute before we move on
just to clarify point it's come up a
couple of times and that's this idea
that there's no difference between a
local needs and a self-build in planning
terms don't forget that they both have
different policies controlling them
similar policies but there are subtle
differences in there and there's
particularly subtle differences over the
locational requirements
which are less strict for local needs as
they are for
self-bills under the emerging sap so I
wouldn't want members to to consider
they are identical because they're not
thank you councilor Keith
um okay
um well I I thought I heard that the
significant weight was being given to
the um
uh the legal duty of the council to
provide more SCP homes is that correct
that you're attach significant weight to
that element that's right yeah and
lesser lesser weight to the emerging sap
no uh to the sap it's limited weight
it's limited weight so so in that
respect I think what I'm seeing is that
it's more important for us to consider
the the SC
the cell phone custom build element of
this in terms of weighting of policies
than it is to the location so for that
reason I would um if if Council Redden
made a proposal
well I'd make a proposal to um
I'd make a proposal to uh
to Grant this application in that case
thank you very much counselor
I will second that proposal chair
thank you very much any further speakers
councilor Harvey
I understand why the officers come to
her conclusion
um I think councilor Perry used the
words common sense
uh
this particular site is not visible
from from the public realm it's it it's
in a settlement which has not yet met
its numbers in terms of allocated to the
um
I'm stuck on finding
um other than saying I would play around
with the waiting
I am inclined to say this is one of
those exceptional cases where I would
say I go along with with granting this
one
um because it's it ends up being a house
in the same location
and
while I would never refer to detailed
considerations planning policy as
dancing on the head of a pin
um I'm my Common Sense bit says this
feels right to do it now to get to their
that conclusion in a justifiable
planning way
um
perhaps needed some help on the
technicalities but if it's a matter of
saying I disagree with the weightings
and therefore
provide even more weight to the
self-build arguments then that's what I
would be prepared to do
common sense to me says if consent's
been given for a house and I do accept
the difference between the two from from
the public realm point of view when that
house is built nobody is going to be
seeing a label on the front of the house
saying local needs or self-build or
whatever they're going to see a house
so I'm inclined to support the the
proposal to to Grant
foreign thank you very much Richard I
think you wanted to contribute
it's helpful that members are talking
about waiting in this way because
they're speaking the language of
plumbers which is always good
um complex so it is and I can see that
members have taken this important point
about our shortfall in self-build and
the fact that it's a significant
shortfall
but in in considering that I'd also ask
you to consider
how far this application goes to meeting
that shortfall because we've had
inspectors decisions and there's been
one in tiddington Road I think it was
where the benefits from one house
towards that shortfall is only moderate
the benefits limited because it's only
one house so I just ask you to bear that
in mind when considering whilst the
shortfall significant how far does this
one application go towards meeting that
shortfall
comment on that thank you very much
that's very helpful
um and in in relation to the shortfall
of housing provision within moreton
Merrill it's even more important in
these circumstances that every
opportunity is taken you could argue in
Morton um to get up to the to the to the
limit of houses that that's specified in
CS cs15 I think so I think that's a
helpful intervention
thank you councilor Pemberton uh thank
you chairman and I was just going to
pick up on Richard's comments
um
yeah it's it's it in the general scheme
of things the addition of one dwelling
makes no difference whatsoever
um this Authority however is is
wrestling with
a particular approach to self-build
which nakedly builds housing Estates
dresses them up as self-build to
circumvent all of the contributions and
all of the location criteria that this
Authority quite rightly puts in place
through its core strategy and its
emerging South Warwickshire local plan
uh so I hope the agents out there are
listening to this
um
therefore actually we should be giving
more weight to single additional self
builds because by definition they tend
to be true self builds and whilst it's
one self-build it's actually one true
self build so
whilst I take the argument on its face
value that it's only one it doesn't add
a great deal actually it sends the right
message out that we're more interested
in proper self build which is one maybe
two three four tops it certainly isn't a
housing estate where you pick from a
catalog
um and um so I think that actually its
importance is greater than that because
self-build by definition is a if we're
going to meet that need properly a
self-build it's going to be one at a
time not 10 20 30 at a time so I'd
probably disagree in in the complex
language of planning with that
assessment and I would give more weight
to the addition of what would truly be a
self-build rather than something dressed
up as self-built
thank you very much councilor Keithley
we'll just add a final point to
councilor pemberton's argument there I
would agree with him but I think this
has also raised the importance of the
issue of knowing where the demand for
self-built houses is and just taking it
on a district-wide basis is in my
personal opinion not enough
thank you any further contributions from
Members okay
um
so we have a proposal to go against
officers recommendations
for reasons of planning balance around
the weighting of the self-build aspect
of it I need to um get conditions um
associated with that
okay on on the assumption that members
are are in favor of this application
these are the conditions that we would
recommend I'll just give you headlines
rather than details so there would be
Standard time limit condition
standard Reserve matters details
commission approved plans
important one to be occupied but built
by a self Builder
shall be a three-bedroom single story
dwelling
the standard bins condition standard
water book condition and the climate
change checklist condition and then we
would have five notes standard mppf note
retention of hedgerows and vegetation
the requirement for a stage one stroke
two safety order Reserve matters
standard fire can fire fighting
condition and standard sewers condition
sorry not condition notes the last five
were notes
okay thank you very much looking just to
make sure proposal and second are happy
with those
yep generally good okay in which case we
can go to the vote so proposal is to
Grant application
with wording delegated to the officers
can I see all those in favor
yes yes
which case uh committee resolves to
Grant application
23.01529 o u t
really good okay
um we'll now move swiftly on to our last
item which is item number six uh
application
22-03735 very uh nelins
Cottage feather Featherbed Lane
ilmington
our presenting officer is Paul Thompson
and once he's in place uh you can take
it away
thank you chair thank you for your
patience members and ladies and
gentlemen uh this is a site in Elmington
which we've seen at committee before
um before I go any further and
reluctantly draw your attention to the
update sheet
um I'll leave you to decide why I'm
reluctant
uh so yeah edge of uh Elmington
this is the site it was originally
granted permission for four dwellings uh
in 2018 I think off the top of my head
uh originally sort of traditional
Cotswold style Cottages uh subsequent
application was granted to vary the the
house type
and this one is to vary the landscaping
or perhaps more accurately to discharge
the landscaping and Vary some elements
of it
uh
first uh element that we're looking at
really is a stone wall across the front
of the site if you can see my uh Red Dot
there that's this area
here is all stone wall on the original
plans
um I'll say original plans the the plans
last approved
on plots three and four which are to the
rear of the site
um there's some estate type fencing it's
not really visible on this plan but it's
it's not a major factor in this
determination
we also have uh boundary fences uh close
boarded 1.8 meter tall
um standard garden fences and finally in
terms of fencing we have stock proof and
rabbit proof fencing because there is
agricultural land to the rear that's
that's behind this section but again it
doesn't play a major factor in the
determination well interestingly you
will note that it's also across the
north of the site here
of which more shortly
last element is
um this has been raised in
correspondence by the parish council
um they don't mention it in their
objection but they have praised it as a
concern
um so it's worth noting 1.5 meter wide
foot path with a grass Verge between it
and the stone wall
so that is what we're working with
proposed instead
we have
the following elements
first of all we have the same stock
proof fencing that's again along the
rear of the site here which you can't
see it's no longer along the north of
the site which makes sense because
that's houses rather than Fields
um
we also have the same metal fencing
metal estate fencing on plots three and
four over here
we have now certainly expanded uh close
border fencing as you'll see across the
north of the site that blue line that's
now close boarded fencing
again that that's to provide privacy to
plot one
finally I think the chief bone of
contention it's fair to say is that the
stone wall along the site Frontage and
uh towards the front elevation of the
house has been replaced with a post and
rail fence it was originally as
submitted this time around going to be
State fencing like plots three and four
but uh we suggested that post and rail
fencing might be a compromise
uh
this
in more detail here shows you that the
footpath has also expanded slightly to
two meters it um as far as I can gather
it has taken that half a meter from The
Verge but the rest of the Verge remains
um
the reason we suggested post rail fence
is uh
Illustrated in this photograph which I
took about noon today and you'll know
there's a poster rail fence immediately
adjoining the site
in the other direction close border
fencing on an on a nearby site an
opposite Hedges along the side of the
road
members my recommendation is that we
Grant permission for this variation uh
thank you chair
thank you very much Paul
um okay so we move on to our only
speaker who's counselor Karen peachy
from illington Parish Council good
evening councilor
uh thank you for being so patient
they're with us this evening you have
three minutes
um yeah it's the button on the right
hand side I'll give you a 30 second
warning otherwise when you're ready to
take it away
good evening councilors
um
when the Netherland Cottages development
originally came before the parish
council we gave it the go ahead
since then the design has changed
significantly
we really feel this development will be
very desirable in an affluent urban area
but not in a village and I realize
that's not the consideration before you
tonight
the footprints of the houses have
increased and when the original
planning came before us it was to
provide affordable housing for the
village
these are no longer affordable houses
they are much larger
we agreed to the stone wall because that
that is a significant feature of the
village
and this has now been changed to
railings and hedging
the reason I'm here tonight is that
these developments and these changes
have actually been implemented
before the planning came before you
and
we really wonder how developers can be
allowed to do this
without receiving the permissions first
and that's all I have to say to you
thank you
thank you very much councilor members do
we have any questions for our Parish
counselor this evening
no oh sorry um councilor Keithley first
and then I'll go well just a
clarification please counselor if you
wouldn't mind
um hi
um you said that they've already
implemented these changes does that mean
the the post narelle fence is already up
because those rail fences are already up
the hedges planted the pavement is
already in place even though you haven't
actually given them permission to do
either any of those changes the house is
all finished and I think the the
photographs would confirm that we might
have another look at that thank you
councilor Harvey
thank you chairman um cancer specie the
case officer in showing us photographs
Illustrated the type of fencing hedging
Walling that's evident in illmington
um
would you agree or disagree with whether
the what is now in place when it comes
to fruition is that in your view
consistent or not consistent with what
it already appears in hillmington uh
post and rail fencing no it's not
consistent there are Stone Walling
higher up the higher up the road on the
left hand side there the close board
fencing yes I'd agree with that that is
evident
um but I think we would have liked to
have seen the stonewalling in place
rather than the post around looks more
like
I don't know a bit farmhouse
I think the issue for us is that
the houses are finished and the paving
is done
and you haven't actually given your
permission
thank you any further questions for our
Parish Council uh no in which case thank
you very much for your contribution
first
I thought it thank you very much
um okay you members uh we may all now
move on to points of clarification from
our officers do we uh councilor Harvey
is right
Mr Thompson you showed a photograph that
photograph which shows
fencing of the Sipe that's being
proposed as I gather in the adjacent
house either on the left hand side of
that photograph has that been approved
sorry Council yes to the best of my
knowledge that has been approved
it wasn't my application I hastened to
it
thank you any further points
clarification
know in which case we can move to the
debate we would like to start
looking around and those are from
councilor Fleming
[Laughter]
someone's going to have to start I'm
afraid who would
otherwise I will pick on someone
counselor Eden
thank you chair
um
as far as objecting to this variation
goes I don't think
there's anything more to be said than to
go with the officer's recommendation
it I would though sympathize with the
counselor in terms of the frustration
that a lot of residents find with
variations happening but that is a part
of the planning process unfortunately
and also the retrospective element of
planning as well and it's something that
we as a committee see quite often that
frustration so I fully sympathize but as
far as material planning considerations
to go against this variation
I can't find any so I'm going to have to
propose that we go along with officers
recommendations on this one
thank you councilor Redden uh caslar
Harvey happy to second
totally good thank you uh yeah I'd like
to sympathize incredibly with the parish
council being a parish councilman myself
as well as a world member I do see
exactly this situation coming up in my
own Ward
um but I'm afraid uh I will agree with
um Council red uh in which case we have
no further contributions
um The Proposal is to go online with the
officer's recommendation and the update
sheet can I see all those in favor
unanimous in which case
committee
resolves to Grant application
22-03735 very
uh uh item seven on the agenda any
urgent business no urgent business in
which case I declare the meeting close
thank you very much